لقد مر عام منذ أن غيّر فيروس
كوفيد الطريقة التي نعيش بها ، حيث كلفنا أرواح
أكثر من نصف مليون شخص
هنا في الولايات المتحدة وحدها ،
والآن يتم الآن إعطاء أكثر من مليوني لقاح
يوميًا ،
وما زلنا نتعامل مع آثار
المعلومات المضللة والمعلومات المضللة
المستعرة من خلال  تنشر سياساتنا الجسدية
الخوف والارتباك
في بداية الوباء
، وجاءت بعض المعلومات المضللة من
وسائل الإعلام اليمينية
وحتى ذلك الحين الرئيس ترامب ، لكن الكثير
من المعلومات المضللة المتعمدة
لا تزال تدفع من قبل
قوى أجنبية مثل روسيا والصين
الآن إذا انقلبت.  إلى fox news
قبل عام واحد ، كنت قد سمعت لورا
إنغراهام
تقول أن هذه الحقائق
مطمئنة جدًا ولكنك لا
تعرف أبدًا أنها تشاهد كل هذه الأشياء
الآن في حين أن عدد الأشخاص المصابين
يزيد عن 650 والآن
يرتفع عدد القتلى إلى 26
خطر  بالنسبة إلى الشخص العادي لا يزال
منخفضًا جدًا
الآن يمكنك القول إنه ليس لديه
معلومات دقيقة أو كما يفعل بعض
زملائها  لقد تم التقليل
من شأنها لأسباب سياسية حزبية
ولكن لا يمكنك قول الشيء نفسه
لترامب الذي أخبر الشعب الأمريكي
قبل عام واحد بالضبط
أننا نقوم بعمل رائع به
وسيختفي فقط ابق هادئًا  اذهب
بعيدًا
، لم يكن يقول الحقيقة لأن
ترامب كان يعلم بالفعل أنها
أشياء مميتة الآن على الرغم من كل
المعلومات الموجودة تحت تصرفه مع
الوعود الكاذبة وعلاجات الدجال ،
سرعان ما أصبح ترامب أكبر
دافع منفرد للتضليل الطمع في
العالم الناطق باللغة الإنجليزية
وفقًا لـ  باحثون في
جامعة كورنيل لكن لاحظوا أنني قلت
التحدث باللغة الإنجليزية
وذلك لأن الصين وروسيا
كانتا وراء الكثير من المعلومات المضللة
التي نشرت الارتباك والمؤامرات
في الداخل والخارج بالطبع
بدأ الفيروس في موهان الصين ،
ونحن نعلم أن الحكومة الصينية
حاولت في البداية  إخفاء الفاشية التي
تعاقب
الأطباء والمراسلين الذين حاولوا
قول الحقيقة وحذروا العالم
في نفس الوقت الذي دفعت فيه الصين إلى  في حملات
التضليل المحلية والعالمية
للابتعاد عن اللوم
في المسيرة الماضية ، قال متحدث باسم
وزارة الخارجية الصينية إنه اقترح عبر
تغريدة أن الجيش الأمريكي جلب
الفيروس بالفعل إلى ووهان وكما أظهرت CNN أن هذا
تحول إلى صحافة كاملة من قبل
الحكومة الصينية للانتشار  نظرية مؤامرة لا أساس لها تلقي
باللوم على الولايات المتحدة في بدء
تفشي المرض في نفس الوقت الذي
كان فيه العملاء
الصينيون يضخمون المعلومات المرغوبة في الولايات المتحدة
عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وحتى النصوص لنشر الذعر والانقسام
الآن كررت جهودهم
تقنيات التضليل الروسية الكلاسيكية ولكن بالطبع
كانت روسيا تلعب  لعبتهم الخاصة
أيضًا في البداية في الاتحاد الأوروبي
ثم نشرها لنا
الآن يدفعون التطهير لتقويض
الثقة في اللقاحات التي
تغذي مخاوف مكافحة التطعيم أثناء محاولتهم
الترويج للقاح الخاص بهم
ليس فقط وفقًا لتقرير جديد صادر
عن  صندوق المارشال الألماني
تلك الجهود الروسية لاقت صدى
في الحسابات المدعومة من الدولة من الصين أ
لا تزال المخاوف التي لا أساس لها من إيران بشأن اللقاحات
تشكل حجر عثرة أمام تعافينا الكامل
من هذا الوباء ،
ولكن ربما يفكر بعض هؤلاء الأشخاص
مرة أخرى إذا أدركوا
أن الدعاية الأجنبية لعبت دورهم ،
لذا استمع إلى أهل العلم لأن
المعلومات المضللة يمكن أن تكون
قاتلة وهذا هو التحقق من الواقع الخاص بك